davos us kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video zu einer neuen folge
elf den elefanten herzlichen service und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
zu einer neuen folge es den elefanten
mit
die nehmen wir jetzt ja denken will das
ist gekauft alles klar okay
und wie immer sind wir hier in jump
world und besucher und meine mappe aus
ja wie immer die maps die mit dem namen
es den elefanten gedeckt wurden werden
eingenommen und wir gucken jetzt mal
welcher das heute sein wird in der
ersten so die erste map des heutigen
tages wird die bergarbeiter hashtag ist
der elefanten seien von eppingen pvp
durchschnittszeit vier minuten 39
durchschnittswerts 26 14 13
gesamtwertung hinter dir ein interview
an
du musst dich auch einfach laufen
einfach leid ich bin schon gelaufen
gehen sie runter das ist sich die ki
aber was mir auffällt
ich will fällt auf dass darunter fällt
es gleich oder ich hab letztens ein
jump'n'run gespielt was genau dieselbe
map war wie diese hier also dieses
leidige thema sag ich mal dass ich so
eine höhle okay und ich dachte zuerst es
der das gebaut hat aber das ist genau
das gleiche hier also ein template wo
man kann also die ganzen template wohl
davon träumen können
also dieser öle hier mit den ganzen
säulen und als mieter weil er genau die
gleichen leute schon mal gespielt
versteh ich noch ein bisschen ich bin
ein bisschen hinten dran ich mal mit auf
drei blöcke abstand stellen so dass ich
es sehen kann
momentan gibt es nicht von mir zu sehen
aber bei doch jetzt hier mal einige
check point update welches update beginn
des gipfels zur ändert kristalle und die
muss man einsammeln und du siehst oben
scoreboard neben derzeit siehst du wie
viele wir brauchen
ok also das steht heute drei sondern
über das zahlen was bringen die an der
kristalle ohne die kannst du das schon
noch nicht fertig machen glaube ich und
wo sind die diese länder müssen so
eingebaut sind
hier findest du schalter krass ich weiß
gar nicht ob man das ich hab keine
ahnung ob man die mitbewohnerin
abschließen kann
das ist habe ich wie diesen super mario
nicht aber da gibt's was zu retten ist
große münzen wieder einsammeln kannst
und die bringen die dann halt im
endeffekt gesamt was aber haben so also
brauchst du nicht an sammeln aber sie
bringen die halt irgendwie was krabbelt
ins ziel und ich hab's geschafft doch
ganz okay alles klar
merck nummer eins damit ist schon wieder
die 20 tradition gebrochen
jetzt muss die theoretischen zwei wins
in folge hinlegen um es hier zu drehen
dann legt sie ins bett gehe
okay die zweite map ist herrschte
gestern elefant wenig kraft und sp von
edf pcc hier und wir springen die
altrhein was ich musste die planes weg
machen gazetten schwert blogs ja du hast
das mittelalter ich muss lebenslänglich
für österreicher links österreicher
müssen erst nach deutschland und dann
rechts gehen
mega auschwitz die drogen waren richtig
hart auf drogen sg auf drogen es case
abnimmt speed lieber mir sind die dinger
ich hab deutschland nationalfahnen ihr
blöcke ich habe österreich das richtig
schwierig alles klappt nicht verstanden
dass ich alles klar gesagt habe und ein
quiz
nein weißt du was ich kriege frage über
deutschland über österreich glaube ich
echt wäre eine solche persönlichkeit
gestorben ich komme gerade nicht auf
dieses ding da drauf hey hey ich bin
sowieso zu behindern wir jetzt häufig
dann in so einem fall schaffen bekommen
random ok alles klar gut jetzt hier die
stille die deutschland pyramide hoch es
ist eng
wer ist der österreichische
bundespräsident heinz fischer werner
faymann ok als bitte bitte bitte bitte
bitte ok das sieht gut aus
weißt du es fällt mir damit basics warnt
philipp kleine mauer herr nicht werner
faymann
der war doch irgendwann als ob das
gleiche wie angela merkel
bundespräsident
ja aber das war aber mehr zu februar ein
österreicher staatsvertrag ja ok er ist
für werner faymann heinz fischer
ja das ist eine österreichische
vorgemacht wie soll ich das fahren ist
falsch jedes kann man sicher streiten
steht schon gar nicht so bin ich jetzt
verfolge ich habe angela merkel mit er
am ende ein gläschen machen heißt okay
er kriegt man checkpoint ich ja gar nix
ich weiß nicht ich glaube ich glaub ich
leute die kannst du dich so bist du
blind alter vor einige alte was ich für
just frankenhof gemacht habe ich habe
die npd zu hoch geworfen landete auf dem
dach von dem ding da und bin übers dach
mit speed an rhein gelaufen
ich habe das nicht gesehen ich habe die
ganze die guckt weil deutschland ist
deutschland teil
und ich hab keine ahnung hast abgibt
irgendwie ist alles eins zu eins die
chance besteht noch und wir springen zur
nächsten map verletzten alles klar leute
die dritte map wird sein es den elefant
von paul meister durch den seit fünf
minuten durchschnittswerts 28 let's go
parteilos sowie ski wenig ratlos rechts
hängt hängt vom blick mit klappt alles
gleich mit auf ein piratenschiff weil es
statt erstes direktes ziel es war
richtig dreist gesehen
direktes ziel gesehen vom anfang an
kontakt nicht hin keine prognose
leider ist echt okay das ist es dann
aber der sich tief versteckt pilsner
arena wasser ist ricky versteckt für
alle leute die abkürzung ist halt gibt
es wieder zwei seiten hier noch ahnung
bitte gibt keine ahnung ich bin ich dran
das ist egal
naja
bis wir ganz vorne ich bin direkt
integriert dann machen wir ja bisschen
langsam mit den jungen pferden land der
berge
nein nein das funktioniert
das ist folge einer manipulation alter
wir müssen nationalen verbieten leute
leute was man dir sollten nationale
verbieten schreibt in die kommentare
und wir sehen in folge pray for pre vom
ok blau gefällt mir gut
in dem blau was wieso nein da muss man
den springt nicht rein laufen ist alter
ich hoffe mein leben nicht mehr ohne
wird sich hoffmann leuchtturm der 630
ist okay jetzt ein checkpoint ja ok
gott deswegen muss ich dann okay ich
habe glaube ich jetzt müssen wir hier
lang alles klar
wir müssen unbedingt wir müssen
unbedingt nationalen verbieten lassen
folge ich habe meine kommentare ob die
nationalen verbieten sollen ich selbst
entwickeln schlechter verlierer sein ich
bin der beste verlierer
also ich finde ich man sollte nationalen
verbieten das aber zu zu krasse
manipulation wenig damit so insgeheim
schon zum österreicher gemacht und man
konnte nicht mehr gewinnen und story
aber leute heute ist auch eine folge es
in erfurt beim video oder gekommen link
ist eine beschreibung der erste link wie
immer
hey leute von effekt hier ich habe mehr
chips als weniger überwindet gewonnen es
besteht die national und ex einfach
nochmal aber okay alles klar ich will
dass euch die entscheidung leute ja
macht's gut